salve
ora essere alla fine sempre abbastanza
beh ho pensato di cominciare in un certo
modo poi in realtà ho sentito due
persone citate laddove iniziato il mio
viaggio nella resilienza abbiamo parlato
di yuan rockstrom da due citato da
giulia soltanto una riccarda ha digitato
your rockstrom era il mio direttore lo
sto come bar menti institute e da lì è
cominciato il mio viaggio dal 2008
probabilmente quel viaggio di ritorno
sono i cervelli in fuga che non è un
termine meraviglioso sono anche i
cervelli di rientro e quando sono
rientrato in italia nel viaggio ricordo
che pensavo e ti ho imparato una parola
nuova meta stavo in estonia
la prima 9 la resilienza avevo in mente
cosa reale significato la resilienza e
avevo anche in mente uno schema che
quello che trovate qua dietro questo a
guardarlo 1 lì viene il panico di james
come faccio a spiegare cos'è la
resilienza eppure in questa questo
grafico si nota quello che è la
resilienza in tutti i suoi legami adesso
andiamo a cercare di capire come come
funziona resilienza la residenza a dei
significati che vengono applicati in
diversi domini della nostra vita c'era
la scienza dei materiali e gli ingegneri
lo sanno bene di solito si descrive
molto bene con la mensola quando si
carica una mensola di libri noi la
quando la mia sulla si piega quando
liberiamo dai libri la messa la torna
quasi allo stato iniziale non è però lo
stesso stato iniziale quella energia che
si libera e la resilienza dei materiali
abbiamo la resilienza nelle scienze
naturali che sono gli ecosistemi io di
solito quando tempo più tempo del tempo
di un piede parlo di solito che quello
che è successo nel porno con queste
calpe gigantesche la settimana scorsa
aveva pescato una da 3 metri ad esempio
quella carta gara che hanno pescato
all'inizio era un animale esterno
all'ecosistema negli anni poi si è
adattato l'ecosistema e c'è stato un
percorso di residenza e ha pure si
genera ancora dei problemi dei disturbi
oggi è parte integrante dell'ecosistema
l'abbiamo in psicologia che forse è la
cosa più bella che abbiamo della
resilienza in psicologia in psicologia e
la capacità degli umani di reagire a uno
shock di solito dicono sempre un po a
tutti noi è successo di essere lasciati
dalla compagna dalla compagna o di aver
perso una persona cara e quando dobbiamo
recuperare dopo questo trauma
impieghiamo del tempo però attiviamo
anche delle capacità che sono nostre
interne sono quelle capacità residenti
che mi affido alla famiglia comincia a
fare qualcosa che comincia a correre ad
esempio che mi dice ho l'obiettivo di
andare a fare a maggio ma di new york
oppure c'è chi si affida a fare le nuove
attività semplicemente e impensate che
dal secondo dopoguerra ad oggi siamo
riusciti a risolvere 13 casi di malattie
mentali grazie alla residenza in
psicologia ma perché perché residenze
psicologia non va più a confinare il
problema ma identifica il problema lo
riconosce e poi dall'edificazione
l'assunzione di responsabilità di dire a
un problema comincia a lavorare sulla
risposta quindi non mi fermo a discutere
e questo è molto tipico italiano io ho
un sogno o andare stasera a bere una
birra con gli amici entrare in un bar e
sentire tutte le persone entro un bar
parlare delle soluzioni per far
ripartire il paese invece quando entri
con vari enti tutti che parlano di
problemi abbiamo una marea di problemi
continuiamo a ripeterci tra di noi che
posso sapere che sia in sono 60 anni
abbiamo sempre gli stessi problemi nel
clima parliamo dissesto idrogelogico 60
anni è sempre la stessa discussione
viene giù la montagna lo sappiamo lemene
di una montagna nelle prime esperienze
di questo viaggio poi hanno cominciato
questo percorso in italia sulla
resilienza una delle prime battute che
mi facevano le persone diciamo ma cos'è
la residenza è un cocktail corte
ebbene in questo viaggio ho scoperto che
un esigenza è un cocktail può essere
anche un cocktail sono arrivato in un
bar a vicenza dove c'è giacomo diamante
che questo bar tender che si è inventato
un nuovo lavoro dove l'alcol non è più
solo una bevanda ma alcune una storia è
un racconto si parla della prima donna a
rizzica stata bartender ad esempio che è
un racconto molto bello che lui fa
perchè ha un simbolo che ha interrotto
ha creato quello che si chiama me ne
vorrà adesso giacomo il sic et bar che
sono i bar del proibizionismo americano
l'ha creato a vicenza e dentro creato un
nuovo modo di vivere il bar decide che
non ci vuole dentro e in questo percorso
è la prima volta che entrò mi chiede di
non ha il menu entra in dice una parola
quello che vuoi vuoi un fiero pellizzaro
io ovviamente sono un po malato di
resilienza e ha detto poi di un
resilienza e lui mi guarda e mi dice ma
dove l'hai già bevuto da nessuna parte
perché è venuto un imprenditore due
settimane fa abbiamo inventato un
cocktail e questo imprenditore l'ha
chiamato resilienza perché è quello che
lui sta facendo nella sua azienda è
un'azienda residente un'azienda che
nella crisi non si ferma ma trovo una
sfida e da questa sfida tira fuori
qualcosa di nuovo di innovativo per
giacomo la resilienza e la capacità di
creare un gusto nuovo un giusto
equilibrio tra quello che la reazione le
reazioni le emozioni che un cocktail può
dare creando nuovi sapori perché c'è un
periodo di choc questo per correttezza è
un altro resilienza non è quello che mi
ha fatto già comunque la sera l'ho
bevuto a maria loca a parigi e questo è
molto bello perché se è composta da tre
parti la parte sopra che è frutto della
passione svuotato dentro un rum che a 70
gradi che ti crea lo shock prima di
berlo è però una parte dolce una parte
bitter perché anche nel processo di
resiliente successiva c'è una parte di
meraviglia quando riesce a dire ho
superato ma poi c'è una parte anche
difficile che è quella della ricaduta
perché c'è sempre una ricaduta non c'è
mai una soluzione definitiva
l'adattamento e continuo perché la
natura e dinamica e questo lo insegna
nella residenza che è diverso la
sostenibilità che alla fine trova un
punto di equilibrio si cerca di trovare
invece oggi non abbiamo scelta diversa
poi nel mio viaggio scoperto che c'è una
pizzeria resilienza e a salerno e
gennaro capito la resilienza la capacità
di creare un giusto equilibrio tra la
natura e la sua capacità di produrre
prodotti genuini senza subire
contaminazioni esterne
nell'alimentazione immaginare una storia
diversa anche era un ristorante prima un
ristorante che è stato come dire
danneggiato
a salerno questa pizzeria non si ferma
dice no io non mi faccio intimorire vado
avanti in italia che reagisce e non solo
fa un nuovo ristorante ma crea un nuovo
legame col territorio utilizza solo
prodotti locali tieni prezzi bassi ma
valorizzando i prodotti sostenibili del
territorio quindi anche nell'equilibrio
in questo ne andate chiama resilienza
che non la bella iniziativa direi questo
fossero più bella che ho visto anche poi
a un certo punto mi imbatto in musei
fantomas è un rapper
canti pop rap italiano e messinese e in
una canzone si chiama resilienza e lui
dice questo è citato testualmente il suo
testo la residenza è sempre stata
un'esigenza vitale per lui per altri
solo un modo per fare soldi ad abbaiare
e lì mi sono sentito coinvolto lo avevo
paura di queste sicilia messina la mia
terra guerriera ripassati la storia poi
parliamo fino a sera e parla di messina
in questa canzone della sua terra una
terra che ha sempre reagito alle
difficoltà e che oggi nelle difficoltà
trova sempre uno spunto se mi chiedete
qual è la città più residente in italia
io vi rispondo che a palermo perché
palermo ha una sua capacità intrinseca
di valorizzare le reti locali i valori e
dare risposta anche meta organizzati di
dare risposte al disagio e alle
difficoltà sociali che sono presenti
nella città insieme mai separati e
quella quella che noi chiamiamo
disordine e realtà un ordine resiliente
delle cose
poi sono arrivato a barre ho messo
vicino scampia per per la medicazione me
ne vogliano del teatro ball perché so
che non vogliono che si faccia questa
questa affiancamento neanche barra non è
scampia però a barra hanno fatto il
carnevale all'incidente e cos'è il
carnevale ma il presidente meglio da chi
è fatto il carnevale residenti che non è
residente è fatto da giovani
tendenzialmente giovani che hanno perso
i genitori per camorra o che comunque
sono vicini a famiglie tendenzialmente
area grosso rischio di infiltrazione
camorristica e loro li coinvolgono
attraverso giochi di strada arte di
strada gli ridanno un sorriso elidan
un'opportunità e ogni anno che erano
questo carnevale resiliente che poi si
diventando itinerante oggi è una
risposta comunitaria a un'emergenza che
non solo del sud italia ma di tutta
l'italia che sono le mafie nel loro
senso più largo e questo si fa a porta
resilienza lettera di una comunità con
il sorriso con la psicologia ma col
divertimento come con la rete perché è
una rete di persone
nella mia vita ha avuto il piacere di
essere parte del primo progetto di
resilienza urbana in italia abbiamo
ottenuto un finanziamento nella
commissione europea è stato fatto un
progetto si chiama blu app v tralascio
l'acronimo in inglese lo dico in
italiano bologna città resiliente e per
il comune di bologna la resilienza è la
lotta ai cambiamenti climatici e
l'obiettivo di rendere il nostro
territorio resiliente non alle emissioni
ma agli impatti perché oggi il
cambiamento climatico è in realtà non è
più un qualcosa che avverrà nel 2050 e
quindi per il comune di bologna
senza la capacità di reagire in maniera
tempestiva a fenomeni imprevedibili
quali alluvioni per il siccità e bufere
di neve e quindi come rendere non solo
il mio comune amministrazione ma anche
gli enti nelle istituzioni che operano
sul territorio capaci di reagire non
solo di adattarci e quindi di prevenire
in un certo senso ma anche di reagire
perché come dicono spesso il concetto
residente di americani o dice spesso il
presidente obama in questo noi dobbiamo
un certo senso si può operare nella
prevenzione ma anche nella capacità di
risposta di reazione troppo spesso
perdiamo tempo a discutere di quello che
è successo
anziché reagire i colleghi di copenaghen
quando anno parlano della residenza
urbana ti dicono sempre che c'è un game
changer lo chiamano ovvero che è la
capacità è un periodo di tempo sei mesi
dopo uno shock dove hai un forte
coinvolgimento della cittadinanza per
poter rispondere attivare nuove risposte
se noi perdiamo questo game changer
abbiamo perso anche l'opportunità della
sensibilità bisogna poi c'è un gioco
quando faccio queste cose qualcuno si
ricorda cosa è successo nel 2003 una
mano se se lo ricorda
black out oltre a black out
peggio di una guerra no peggio di una
guerra un'ondata di calore
abbiamo avuto quasi 70.000 morti in
tutta europa e noi non ce lo ricordiamo
abbiamo avuto in un'estate più morti di
una guerra e nessuno se lo ricorda le
ondate di calore sono l'evidenza
dell'impatto del cambiamento climatico e
se non diamo risposte a questo noi non
saremo capaci di prevenire e difendere
quelle che non sono soprattutto due
generazioni c'è la generazione più più
vecchia un certo senso che porta con sé
la memoria che è una parte fondante
della resilienza e i bambini che sono i
soggetti più deboli che sono il nostro
futuro che alla resilienza la memoria e
l'innovazione perché questa è la
residenza nella comunità saper coniugare
quello che sapevamo fare e
ammodernandolo con le nuove innovazioni
come sento parlare prima
dopo di che è successo che la città di
milano ha ottenuto abbiamo posto il suo
percorso verso la resilienza urbana è un
qualcosa che è iniziato da poco per il
comune di milano nella residenza è
capace di dare risposta con una stessa
nazione a più fattori di rischi noi oggi
abbiamo sempre abituati nelle città
siamo in un centro bellissimo ma le
nostre periferie chi se lo ricorda ce ne
scordiamo senza le periferie centri
storici non vivono nelle periferie si
affrontano e vivono i rischi maggiori
delle nostre società per questo il
comune di milano dice yo diversi fattori
un'emergenza a casa dove devo
intervenire per dare risposte
all'emergenza casa posso fare una cosa
oltre a rendere più vivibili quegli
spazi per rendere appunto le case più
accessibili più vivibile in un certo
senso posso anche dare una risposta al
cambiamento climatico come lo possiamo
fare possiamo prendere degli esempi di
cose che già fanno a rotterdam fanno le
piazze d'acqua vengono chiamate quindi
trasforma una piazza nuovamente noi
facciamo cosa facciamo di solito su una
piazza e facciamo un bel parcheggio
sotto perché comoda noi dobbiamo andare
a fare il supermercato che a 200 metri
prendiamo la macchina
indiani marchio con meno 25 vanno in
bicicletta quindi quando un italiano
dice non uso la bicicletta perché fa
freddo fa freddo in italia e quindi per
il comune di milano la capacità è quella
di ritornare a lavorare sulle periferie
e coniugare i fattori multipli fattori
di rischio in un'unica risposta perché
nella esigenza è anche questo e
l'interdipendenza che esiste tra i
diversi settori sono i termini portanti
di quelli che sono anche quei 24 anni
campani tribù android che cita gli oil
roxon nell'altro pò cene e
l'interdipendenza dei diversi fattori
dobbiamo smettere non rompere i silos in
cui siamo chiusi ognuno di noi e alla
nostra specializzazione e lavorare
insieme su diversi fattori per che cosa
vuol dire costruire la resilienza dalla
fine vede sono partito dalla fine dalle
soluzioni per far vedere che la
residenza è già in essere non c'è
bisogno di farla di meritarsela perché
significa aumentare la capacità di una
comunità di sopravvivere recuperare e
prosperare in condizioni economiche
sociali e climatiche mutevoli prima
durante e dopo uno shock noi costruire
denso abbiamo essere capaci di prevenire
ma di rispondere e rispondere in tempi
brevi
dobbiamo aspettare che succeda un'altra
volta come è successo di recente in
italia
senza citare sul regista le diverse
città è mio passo fa un vicentino
citiamo stiamo la mia e sono vicentina
perché la resilienza poi parte
banalmente da delle lievi delle funzioni
vitali che abbiamo fondamentali in un
territorio abbiamo le risorse idriche
abbiamo le risorse energetiche abbiamo
le infrastrutture le aree verdi la
mobilità urbana tutte le attività
produttive la tutela della biodiversità
la salute e benessere ai trasporti
pubblici e tutto in un'unica soluzione
che la residenza perché abbiamo una
visione la residenza non è mi hanno
chiesto come facciamo a calare la
residenza a desenzano sicana è insieme
che si innesca una nuova capacità di
vedere il futuro e di vedere le
interconnessione che esistono tra le
diversi aspetti della nostra vita
quotidiana perché in tutti noi residenza
perché gli elementi che compongono la
nostra società di oggi ci sono dei
rischi e arrivo a quello doveva essere
la premessa
oggi abbiamo onestà del rischio lo
definiva ulrich beck la società del
rischio che è venuto a mancare dalla da
poco e se pensate a quelle a questi
rischi che ho messo qui sono gli stessi
che ho citato prima la criminalità
organizzata
l'economia globale cambiamenti climatici
sociale l'alimentazione l'acqua e le
migrazioni
potrei citarvi altre esperienze di
resilienza abbiamo le si evidenzia nel
settore bancario sono i primi gr usano
le banche guarda caso e l'hanno fatto
dopo la crisi oggi hanno sostituito
l'altro giorno hanno inaugurato a
francoforte le autorità di vigilanza
sulle banche qualcosa che non esisteva
una cosa assolutamente positiva ma nella
nostra economia la nostra prima fonte
delle esigenze sono le piccole e medie
imprese
io sono quel tessuto che è capace di
innovare o un esempio meraviglioso mi è
rimasto impresso di treviso dove un
imprenditore produceva pantaloni e
tessile che produciamo in serie a poi si
arriva ticinesi ha detto oddio adesso
come faccio io non voglio chiudere si è
messo a pensare ha preso i vecchi telai
e oggi non produce più pantaloni in
serie intreccia tutela nei particolari
fa 4 uniche questione più ma sono di
qualità ea me sul proprio operaio bene
primo lo immagino e mezzo e adesso cosa
faccio non so mi sa come andare avanti
la messa davanti a un telaio gli ha
detto per tre giorni tu impari ad usarlo
quello oggi è capace usare un telaio
vecchio non usa più il pulsantino ed è
molto più contento perché si sente anche
più manuale più capace è un recuperato a
50 anni ha recuperato anche una funzione
attivato dalle sue funzioni anche di
pensiero e da una persona felice in
questo è perché la resilienza cosa ci
dici tu dici che dietro ogni problema
c'è un'opportunità perché alla fine se
ci pensate io penso che dopo questo lo
volevo spera di trasmettervi e che se ci
pensate ognuno di voi e resiliente e
ognuno di noi ha una capacità residente
proprio interno perché alla fine nella
residenza siamo noi non sono gli altri e
tutti insieme possiamo dare risposte a
quelle che sono oggi i problemi di un
paese che affronta un dato host un dato
domenica inquietante che però non è un
problema è un'opportunità abbiamo sei
milioni di persone che vivono in povertà
assoluta in questo paese con dato istat
non è un dato di qualunque a queste sei
milioni di persone devo dare delle
risposte e queste risposte che ho
provato a mettere sms al sistema possono
essere una risposta a uno di questi
problemi è volata sul tra disoccupazione
giovanile
questo nel 60 per cento dei giovani è
disoccupato nel sud italia senza andare
a prendere la quota delle donne che
ancora peggio in questo la residenza è
una risposta che possiamo dare alle
crisi sistemiche c'è per farlo dobbiamo
cominciare a parlare con chi ci sta di
fianco chiedergli cosa fa ea quella
persona soprattutto sorridiamo perché
anche attraverso la felicità di aver
sentito grazie